the crisis is over
things are looking up again that's what
the european union commission is telling
us for month
so are the big problems really over
or will the ukraine crisis and the
strong euro become an obstacle for the
recovery that's what i'm talking about
with deutsche bank research expert
oliver raquel
mr raka first of all let's have a look
on the dbx
please tell us how has the world economy
developed in april
the dbx actually went up in april that's
mostly due to the improvement in the
united states as well as in europe or in
germany
in the united states we have a recovery
after the very weak winter driven first
quarter and in germany we have a
generally domestically driven upswing
whereas in china in japan
the things look stable but not exciting
on the growth side
so is it very optimistic of the european
union commission to say the
european economy will grow by 1.2 this
year uh that's actually pretty much our
forecast as well uh we have i think 1.1
so about the same uh that's not
optimistic i think that's a baseline
most participants on the markets see
about the same growth rate
problematic is still how far the
divergence is inside of europe we have
germany with much stronger growth
and we have the peripheral countries
that still struggle with the
restructuring of their economies
the ukraine crisis seems to be a big
risk for the recovery
what do you think how much could it
affect the european economy that's
really difficult to say because you
simply do not know how things will play
out
we are currently still thinking that
things are not going to escalate much
further
and if that's the case then the effects
for the overall economy shouldn't be too
large given the fact that europe is not
that dependent on the export side on
russia and ukraine
but if things should escalate
you could approximate that by looking at
the russian crisis in the late 90s
at that time
gdp went down by 10
there
and that approximately translate to 0.5
percentage points lower growth uh in
germany that would still mean about 1
growth in germany so from that
perspective as long as things don't
escalate too much further
the european economy should be fine
many european countries are complaining
about the very high euro exchange rate
what can be done about that is it really
important to do anything right now in
fact that's a big question
generally speaking uh exchange rates
develop on markets and you cannot really
do that much of course central banks
have an effect on that
but you also have a lot of capital
inflows into the european monetary union
and these have been strong supporting
the euro
but that should stop at some point which
would again be less of an impetus for
the exchange rate also you have a
strengthening u.s economy which should
strengthen the dollar versus the euro
so all in all speaking
they shouldn't be done that much because
things are likely to change anyway
but currently a lot of market
participants expect the ecb to do
something in june at least
we will talk about this later on thank
you so far mr rakau
yes well strong euro weak economy
you can watch the full interview on dw
dot de slash english slash made in
germany